Daredevil was actually a pretty cool, legit
comic book, until the Affleck Attack happened.
But the idea of blindness enhancing other
senses is just fiction... isn't it?
Hey gang, Trace here for DNews!
Thanks for tuning in.
There's a common thing in superhero and fantasy
media... if one sense is lost, the others
get better to compensate.
Do senses really DO that?
The research says yes!
The brain is a glutton for input, so if you
restrict the input channels it freaks out.
Sensory deprivation tanks are this in a nutshell.
Research from the Journal of Nervous and Mental
Disease found, when people were placed in
a sensory deprivation room, the brain couldn't
tell if the thoughts and images it was creating
were inside the head, or outside the body.
When deprived of input the volunteers would
experience visual hallucinations, paranoia
and a depressed mood -- all this, with less
than 15 MINUTES of loss of input.
So, if that's what happens with ALL the senses
dulled, what about with just one?
Studies HAVE shown blind people experience
a higher sound placement ability, and increased
sense of touch.
This has to do with the brain literally REFORMING
to take resources from the missing sense.
A study in the Journal of Neuroscience used
fMRIs to scan the brains of people who were
born deaf.
They found their senses of sight and touch
were altered... and they found a boost in
the understanding bimodal stimuli.
Bimodal stimuli boosts are commonly seen in
those who are bilingual -- they have a lot
more crosstalk between their senses.
This means people born deaf SEE the world
differently than a fully sensed person!
Now, knowing ALL that -- does someone who
BECOMES blind gain sense-power?
A study that came out last week says FOR SHIZZLE.
Researched published in the journal Neuron
found when fully sensed mice had blindness
simulated for as little as one week -- their
hearing was boosted.
The researchers said this has to do with how
the senses work together.
Kind of like in a movie, if what you're seeing
doesn't match what you're hearing -- you'd
get messed up.
Your vision is supremely tied to what you're
hearing.
Their experiments found sight helps us hear
softer sounds, and have better pitch!
Because of that, your sight can help work
with your hearing to help discern talking
or familiar music in a loud environment.
If you take what you're seeing AWAY however,
your hearing has to do it alone -- and it
flips switches in your brain called thalamocortical
inputs.
This lets the auditory information borrow
some of the processing power of the visual
center.
It seems to me this is kind of like Daredevil's
power!
He's using his VISUAL center to understand
the perceived SOUND.
This has been documented in others too, people
who are blind yet can navigate an unfamiliar
room, and even ride a bike.
The switches they're talking about, are normally
not used in adults -- but in a week of blindness?
BAM.
Switched.
Very cool.
They also found when they removed the blindness,
the switches went back to normal -- so it's
reversible.
Super cool.
Would you go blind for a week, for science?
Think of all the things you could hear!!
Come tell us down below, we read the comments
and love to chat.
Thanks for watching DNews, hear you later!